jours comment vous avez ressenti ce
grand oral des manuels macron qui est
bien est à la tête de la présidence
française de l'union européenne alors
écoutez grand oral je ne sais pas en
fait en réalité tout ce qu'il a dit il
avait déjà dit par le passé il n'y a
rien de fondamentalement je dirais
nouveau dans ce qu'il a pu exprimer ce
matin devant le parlement ce que je
dirai simplement c'est que les ambitions
qui semble vouloir afficher en réalité
pour un certain nombre d'entre elles
sont déjà inscrits dans des dans le
parcours de l'union bien évidemment et
puis de nos pays membres mais que
l'ambition sur un certain nombre de
sujets tels que je ne sais pas du tout
comment nous allons pouvoir y arriver à
27 la matière justement on parlait sur
notre plateau de livres et j'ai le
présent à un public qui est favorable et
bien à l'introduction du droit les vg
dans la charte des droits fondamentaux
européens ce serait une bonne idée non
ce n'est pas une bonne idée pour une
raison toute simple c'est que
aujourd'hui on voit bien que pour
beaucoup de sujets il est indispensable
d'avoir l'accord de l'ensemble des états
membres là en l'occurrence nous sommes
encore dans sur un sujet très sensible
pour lequel on le sait bien nous avons
notamment deux pays la pologne et malte
sachant que nous avons eues présidente
maintenant du parlement qui est maltese
et qui s'oppose à lille et j'ai donc moi
je voudrais bien qu'on m'explique
comment notre président envisage pendant
ce laps de temps qui en plus s'est
quelque peu amputé de par nos élections
nationales
envisage d'arriver à convaincre autant
d'états membres pour se mettre d'accord
sur un sujet aussi sensible pour lequel
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas véritablement
de consensus c'est donc ça voudrait dire
qu'un et à la pologne et une présence du
parlement européen le mâle thèses anti
viger ça pourrait bloquer cette
reconnaissance du droit à l'avortement
je crois que c'est un travail que chaque
pays doit faire au simple de sa propre
le son de ses propres frontières en
france c'est un travail qui a été fait
depuis longtemps nous avons beaucoup
avancé sur ces thématiques là d'autres
pays je cite aussi l'irlande 1 tout
récemment qui a quand même fait un grand
pas dans ce sens là pour les femmes et
il me semble que c'est un petit peu
allez j'ose le dire un peu prétentieux
de la part de notre président dans le
contexte actuel d'annoncer cela comme ça
comme étant une grande ambition parce
qu'on sait bien que sur de longs enfin
pendant cette présidence on n'y arrivera
pas sur l'environnement qui est un de
vos sujets de prédilection emmanuel
macron là aussi à renforcer la
protection de l'environnement dans les
textes européens ça par contre ce serait
une bonne idée ou oui c'est une bonne
idée bien sûr est d'ailleurs appelée
vous à l'occasion de la loi climat nous
mêmes ici nous nous sommes prononcés
tous groupes confondus
en préambule
mais là encore nous y travaillons en ce
moment même la commission des affaires
européennes nous travaillons avec mon
collègue d'ailleurs jean yves le conte
sur ce qu'elle a justement de l'objectif
55 dans le cadre du green deal européen
donc le sénat fait en tapant
sur le même sujet donc là encore jeudi
raymond on s'inscrit notre présidence
française de l'union s'inscrit dans la
continuité des ambitions fortes comment
on va y arriver c'est un autre débat
puisque il faut mettre tout cela en
corrélation avec notre stratégie bas
carbone stratégie nationale bas carbone
et il faut se dire que depuis 90 nous
avons baissé que de 2 24% l'objectif
donc 55 voyez il nous reste encore un
grand pas à franchir mais le chemin est
encore long
[Musique]